Aawdubillahi mina shaytana rajim Bismillahir Rahmanir Rahim Alhamdulillahi saani ilkhalqi alaquli akmali nizam wa ahsani kawaam Alwadi ala shiaifi ajdaril maqam wa arfaqi masaam wassalatu wassalamu 'alal mu'ayyidi abla ghil kalam Muhammadinil mabruth sallallahu alaihi wa ala alaihi wa salam
Lihidaa yatikaa Fati Anam ila subulis salaam wa ila madalla yali wala yam Walhamdulillah Alladhilam yattakhiz waladan walam yakunlahu Sharikun fil Mulk walam yakunlahu wal yumina zullay wa kabbir hu taqbirah Walhamdulillah Alladi anzala ala Abdhil kitab walam yaja Allahu aywaja
Alhamdulillah Alladinahmaduhu wa nastaainuhu wa nastaqfirhu wa nu'minubihi wa natawakkalu alai Wa na'udubillahi min shururi anfusina wa min sayyi ati 'aamalina man yahdihillahu fala mudillala wa man yudlilhu fala hadi Allah Wa nashadu an la ilaha illallah wahtahula sharikala Wa nashadu anna Muhammadana Abdullahi wa rasulih
Arsalahullahu ta'ala bilhudawadeen al-haq li yozhirahu aladdinikulli wa kafabillahi shaheedah Wa nashhadu anna mawlana ali ibn Abi Talib wasiyihu wa waziru Fasallallahu alayhim wa ala alayhim wa salim hum tasliman kathiran kathira Allahum mala 'ilmalana illama alamtana inna kaantal ali mulhakeem
Allahumma alimna bima yanfa'na wa yanfa'na bima alamtana Allahumma inna na'udhubika min Ail min la yanfa wa min qalbin la yaksha wa min aainin la tadma wa min nafsin la tashba Fa'amma baadi akkullu subhana wa ta'ala fi kitaabihil kareem baada akkulla a'udhubillahi mina shaytana rajeem bismillahir rahmanir rahim
Rabbish Rahli Sadri Wa Yasirli Amri Wahlul Iqdatam mill Lisani yafqahu Qawli Allahum masabitna ain dalmauti bila ilaha illallah wallahum majaal naamin Alladhina amanu amil salihat wa tawa sau bil haq wa tawa sau bis sabr ameen ya rabbil alameen As-salamu alaikum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatu.
In the last session, I talked about the word 'ilah' and its various flavors and meanings.
We learned that when the definite article 'the' or 'al' in Arabic, when it gets applied to 'ilah', it becomes 'al ilah'.
And both of those words then fuse together to form 'Allah'.
So, all the various meanings of ilah then become exclusive for the one that we call Allah.
That's what the Al does.
So now, if I take the meaning of ilah as a powerful entity that demands submission, then Allah becomes the one, the only one for me.
Right?
He becomes al-ilah for me.
The only one I deem worthy of my submission.
He becomes the only one I must be completely loyal to.
Because there is no one more powerful than Him.
And it is He who created the heavens and the earth in reality.
And the day He says be, it becomes.
His word is the ultimate truth and He has all dominion on the day the trumpet will be blown.
He is the knower of the unseen as well as the seen.
And He is wise and He knows everything.
And then the same formula applies to the rest of the meanings of Ilah.
If we take the meaning of Ilah as seeking protection and refuge, then Allah is the only one I exclusively turn to for protection and refuge in desperate times.
If I take illah in the meaning of love, then Allah becomes the only one I choose to be passionately in love with.
He is the only entity, the only deity that I choose to be completely obsessed about.
For all the infinite favors that He bestows upon me,
Knowing well that I am an extremely ungrateful and unworthy creature, He does not hold back in bestowing His favors upon me.
Wa atakum min kullima sa altumuhu wa in ta'udu na'amatallahi la tahsuha innal insana lazaluman kafura And He gave you
of all that you asked for.
And if you try to count the blessings of Allah, you will never be able to count them.
Indeed, no doubt about it, man is an extreme wrongdoer, a disbeliever, an ungrateful being.
Now, if I take the meaning of ilah in the sense of wallaha, of astonishment,
then Allah becomes the only one whose glory and whose magnificence astonishes me.
I realize that even when I set out to understand Him, when I venture to recognize Him, I do so with the realization that His loftiness will exhaust my limited capabilities of comprehension and understanding.
I will be dumbfounded every single time I attempt to approach Him.
Because there is just nothing that is comparable to Him.
And there are no words that can express His glory.
If the sea were to become ink,
In order to write the words of my master, indeed the sea would be exhausted before the words of my master would be finished.
Even if he brought something similar to the oceans to assist, the words of my master cannot be captured.
The praise of my master cannot be captured.
So that's Walaha.
Finally, if I take ilah in the meaning of the one that I lean on for support, then Allah becomes the only one that I choose to lean on.
He becomes the only one I choose to put my entire weight of all my spiritual burden on for support.
Because His support is the only support that matters.
In yansurakum Allaha falaagaalibalakum
If Allah helps you, no one can overcome you.
And if He forsakes you, then who is there after Him that can help you?
And in Allah, let alone the believers put their trust.
So, in other words, there are all these different meanings
these various rivers of knowledge that flow out of the word ilah and they all then become exclusive.
They all converge into one entity when it reaches the al-ilah or Allah.
But the real question is what do we get out of the union of all these meanings of ilah?
So if Allah is the only powerful entity deserving submission, if Allah is the only one capable of providing refuge and protection, if Allah is the only one worthy of passionate love and obsession for my thoughts, and if Allah is the only one who astonishes me, astounds me, if Allah is the only one I choose to lean and depend on,
Then the union of all these meanings of ilah with its exclusivity of Allah, making Him Allah, what does the union of these meanings produce for me?
What does all of this mean to me?
What does this make Allah to me?
They make Allah worthy of my worship.
They make Him worthy of my ibada.
This is why He created me.
And I did not create jinn or the humans except that they should worship me.
And this is why He says that.
Because the sum of all these meanings of ilah, they make him worthy of my worship.
This is why every single day, in every single namaz, I say, Iya ka nabudu wa iya ka nasta'in.
It is only you that we worship, and it is only you that we seek help from.
This concept of Al-Illah, what it leads us to is the idea of worship, the idea of Ibada.
And the one we worship is called Maabud.
We are the Abd and Allah is our Maabud.
Now, what is worship?
The word Ibada is commonly translated as worship, right?
But linguistically speaking,
The word ibada actually means a combination of two things.
It means to worship and it also means to obey, both at the same time.
They're not interchangeable like many other words in the English language.
No.
Both meanings of worship and obedience are embedded inside this one word of ibada in the Arabic language, in classical Arabic.
Together,
They both mean Ibadah.
You cannot take one meaning out of this word.
It is worship and it is obedience.
But generally, when we think of the word worship, what comes to our mind?
The five prayers, fasting, paying Zakat, performing Hajj, right?
These are all different forms and the rituals of worship.
So it is worship.
But these are the rituals of worship.
But what happens is that we think that's it, and we stop at all of those activities.
And that's the point that I want to highlight today.
The problem with this translation of the word ribada exclusively in the meaning of worship is that it does not necessarily include the concept of obedience.
Especially an obedience that stems out of love.
That is critical to understand.
That is extremely important to understand.
Worship is a love-based obedience.
Because the word obedience, it can have a very negative connotation to it, right?
Because people can be forced into obedience.
Children are often bullied into obedience by the use of either threats or violence.
So it is possible for obedience to have a very negative emotion attached to it.
But this is not the kind of obedience that we're talking about here when we say Ibadah.
Ibadah is an obedience that comes naturally from the appreciation of all these various meanings of ilah that we learned.
When we choose to love Allah passionately, when we choose to become obsessed about Him, when we are completely devoted and loyal to Him, when we completely trust Him and lean upon Him,
When we're totally impressed and amazed by His loftiness, His greatness, His magnificence, when we know that we can always unconditionally turn to Him for protection and refuge, then the natural outcome of the sum of all of these love-based emotions is obedience.
So remember that Ibada is an obedience that stems out of love.
It is a lover's obedience to make the beloved happy.
And this is why Allah created us.
And this is why He gave us this ability to love.
He did not create us and desire disobedience from us.
He allows disobedience.
His magnificence enables this capability of disobedience within His creation because disobedience is a product of free will.
which is called Khizlaan.
But Allah is not content with it, because disobedience is completely contrary to the concept of love.
You know, there's a poet by the name of Mahmud al-Warraq, and in one of his poems he says,
You disobey Allah and then you feign the love of God?
This is an impossible and unknown kind of logic.
Had your love been sincere, you would have been obedient.
Because a lover is always obedient to the one he loves.
So, it is the nature of love that we want to obey the one that we love.
In another one of his poems, he says, .
You know, a woman once asked someone about the state of this person who loves her with this burning passion.
Ashik is the one who is burning up with passion.
Right?
They say, Dawa ul aishq ali tisal.
The only cure for aishq is to be connected with the beloved, to be in the embrace of the beloved.
So, she's talking about this man, she's asking about this man who loves her, and she's inquiring about his love for her.
And this is something that lovers do, right?
They want to know, they inquire from others about how much their beloved loves them.
So, she asks this man, Lillahi sifhu, walatanqus walatazidi.
For Allah's sake, describe him to me and don't stint in your description and don't exaggerate.
In other words, you know, I want to know the truth.
I want to hear the truth.
So, this man, he says, Lawkana rahlil mauti bid duma'i.
If your lover thought that he would die from thirst, Waquti qifan wurud al ma'i lam yaridi.
And if you said don't touch that water, he wouldn't touch it.
So her lover knows that he is going to die of thirst, but if the woman said don't touch that water, he wouldn't touch it.
He'd rather die than disobey.
So the point of that, what he's emphasizing there is that the nature of love is obedience.
So the more you love Allah, the more you will want to obey Him.
So Ibadah to Allah has these two concepts embedded within it: worship and obedience.
Both of which stem out of this passionate love for Him
and not from some kind of forced compulsion or coercion.
And to put this in practical terms, to give you an example, let's say, you know, we are about to pray in 15 minutes, right?
Let's say it's Fajr time.
And so we have to pray.
We have to do our Ibada.
We have to go through the ritual of prayer.
Now, what kind of Ibada is prayer, Salat?
Is it worship or is it obedience?
It's worship, right?
But then from Fajr all the way up till Zuhr, we will not be worshipping him through this ritual of prayer, but if we are sincere in our love for him, we will be doing what?
We will be obeying him.
We will be in a state of obedience with him.
Because it is the dream and the desire of every lover to make their beloved happy.
And so the beauty
of this word ibada is that it covers the entire spectrum of love, putting us in a constant state of worship.
You see, when we are performing the ritual acts of Salat, we are in a state of ibada.
But then when we are in between two prayers, by being in a state of obedience, we are still in the state of ibada.
You see, this is why
the concept of ibada is so comprehensive in Islam we are constantly in a state of worship if not through the formal rituals then through obedience so what this means is that if you go in the morning and earn a halal income through your job that is an act of obedience that is an act of ibada when you go to school
and you sincerely accomplish the purpose of education, you're in a state of ibadah, you're worshiping.
When you love and respect your elders, when you are kind to your siblings, when you're generous to the needy, when you're courageous in the face of temptations, no matter what you do, as long as you're in a state of obedience and servitude to Allah , anything and everything that you do becomes an act of ibadah.
It becomes worship.
It turns into worship.
Going to the toilet becomes Ibadah.
Imagine that.
When you go to the toilet to relieve yourself, if you obey the commands of Allah to cover your head and feet and seek His protection and recite all those duas, you're in a state of Ibadah.
So you can see that this concept of worship of Ibadah is really incredible in Islam.
And may Allah give us all the strength and Tawfiq to become his obedient slaves and to fulfill the purpose of our creation.
Wa akhiruda wanaan alhamdulillahi rabbil alameen wassalatu wassalam aala Rasulahi Saidira Muhammadin Khatimin nabi yeen was sayyid al-mursaleen wal akhihi wa wassi yaalib nabi Talib asharafil wassi yeen wa 'alal aimmatimin zariatima taibinatahirin wassallam alayhi majma'in al-fatiha